this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one New York Times best seller
I've also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
dot-com forward slash Tim this episode
is brought to you by wealth front and
this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly their
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the
value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15 thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealth front that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront
Inc is an SEC registered investment
advisor investing in securities involves
risks and there is the possibility of
losing money past performance is no
guarantee of future results please visit
wealth front comm to read their full
disclosure so check it out guys this is
one of the hottest most innovative
companies coming out of Silicon Valley
and they're killing it they've become
massively popular just take a look see
what portfolio they would create for you
and you can use that information however
you want wealthfront comm forward slash
Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers to
tease out the routines habits influences
books etc that you can use or apply to
your own life and in this episode I sit
down with Edward Norton at Edward Norton
on the Twitter's please say hello to him
Edward is an actor filmmaker and
activist of course he's been nominated
for three Academy Awards for his work in
primal fear American History X and
Birdman he has starred in scores of
other films including the iconic Fight
Club
the things you own end up owning you the
illusionist and moonrise kingdom among
many many others unbeknownst however to
many people Edward is also a serial
startup founder he is a human ambassador
for biodiversity a massively successful
investor for instance very early in
Oberer and perhaps a half a dozen other
unicorns a pilot and deeply involved
with wilderness conservation and as luck
would have it at this exact moment I am
involved with one of his startups
Crowdrise I have a campaign on there
with Johns Hopkins supporting some
fascinating psychedelic research check
it out it is to address treatment
resistant depression it's fascinating so
go to Crowdrise dot-com forward slash
Tim Ferriss to check it all out and we
have a very wide-ranging conversation we
cover a lot including his beginnings
what early mentors taught him some cool
Marlon Brando's stories his physical
prep for American History X surfing
favorite books documentaries underrated
films and filmmakers that Reindeer bell
sound is Molly doing a little jig in the
background and there also some cats and
heat outside my partner for some reason
so excuse the extra-curricular sound
catastrophe of success would be one of
the essays for instance his advice to
his twenty and thirty year old self and
much more one bonus a book that he
recalled one of his favorites after we
stopped recording which I wanted to
include is Buddhism without beliefs and
without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with the incredible Edward
Norton
Edouard welcome to the show thanks I am
sitting here looking out at the surfers
and I know we got to start today because
you had a session earlier this morning
and it seems like surfing is a big part
of your life I know this is maybe a
place to start but how long has that
been the case it's definitely my most
positive addiction I think I started I
actually my father lived in Indonesia
from like 2005 for about seven years and
I was making a film in China called The
Painted Veil and toward the very end of
the film
I got chucked off a horse doing a shot
and I broke my back in three places
fortunately didn't hurt my spine at all
just cracked three vertebrae and was
really lucky but my back was like a my
back was like a an oak table with no
articulation in it between my neck and
the bottom of my ass and so I I couldn't
twist I couldn't like been you know it
was really really racked and
and locked up and and when the film
ended my dad had just moved to Indonesia
so I went down there for a couple months
to hang out with him and just try to
recover a little bit and and I was like
swimming and doing yoga and getting
massages and things like that and I
there was a surf school on one of the
beaches there and I'd always wanted to
do that and started realizing that it
you know it forced you into a reversed
kind of bowed position that was exactly
what I was having trouble doing and so
initially I started doing it just taking
a big padded board and Pat and paddling
you know just to try to increase my
endurance and having my back arched and
and from there it just I got completely
hooked on it
it seems to undo a lot of the through
postural II induced problems of people
who use computers too often right I mean
you have this sort of protracted rounded
back and then when you're forced into
that thoracic extension even for you
know a half a minute of Pat or half an
hour of paddling or a few hours of
paddling it just seems to undo and
balance all that out it's some it's
great it's great physically it's it's
actually great aerobic ly it's um it
uses muscles in really weird ways and
you have to be nimble and retain your
ability to like hop up you know and
you've you know you read you're looking
at moving water all the time and I
always say like trying to figure out the
micro variations in waveforms and the
way they're moving at you and where you
should position yourself on them is
better than any video game you know it's
it's there's no video game that's more
complex than then trying to read the
nuances of moving water and put yourself
in the right place and it's just I
actually
totally not facetious I it's a it's an
addiction I think it it I have friends
who were serious addicts heroin addicts
you know really struggle with things who
have replaced that with surfing because
it it it hits parts of the brain I think
that are completely um you know it's
like dopamine and serotonin all at once
and you you come out of it so
blissed-out and kind of um you know we
talked we were talking about this
earlier like like it's like a reboot on
the on this on your stress on your
crowded mind on all of it I just I just
think I should meditate more than I do
except I do surf and I feel like that's
the I combined I get the meditative
value out of surfing I think the
mindfulness aspect of it is and I'm not
a good surfer although I enjoy surfing
poorly but the the fact that the train
is always changing like you said makes
it very distinct from something that you
might think of as similar like
snowboarding right you constantly have
to be in a present state have a present
state awareness of where you are
relative to your surroundings where you
are relative to other people it's just a
it's it's a necessity that you're paying
attention to what's happening in the
here now yeah it's great it's a it's I
it also you know it makes me play hooky
more than I do otherwise I I I'll I'll
suddenly find myself you know more able
to to be confident that I can push other
things to the side I can't explain it I
it it it recalibrates my sense of
urgency around my to-do list mm-hmm you
know yeah it sort of alleviates the
manufactured emergencies something
exactly yeah what other morning rituals
do you have that you find helpful or
have you had
I wish I had better ones is the honest
answer I'm I wish I I think I would
benefit from from creating more ritual
morning routines that are positive be it
like exercise first thing when I'm not
surfing or meditation or anything that
sort of you know as a matter of practice
starts the day in a in a in a mindful
way or what however you want to put it
you know i i i i do often
just let the day begin by opening up the
cascade of emails or things i think i'm
supposed to do or you know it's it's
it's not the right way to jumpstart the
mind and i it's probably probably up
that's a category i should do better on
so I'm obsessed with routines of course
different types of habits maybe we could
I've wanted to ask you this I'm actually
astonished I haven't asked you this
before in our previous conversations but
when you were getting ready for the role
in American History X what type of
training did you do for that what did
your training regimen look like it was
it was pretty specific it was pretty
specific to building mass like I am NOT
doing that film created the strangest
distortion of perception on me and I
know that's a weird thing to say but
like it was it's unbelievable the degree
to which that film and the magic of
camera and art and black and white
photography and all these things
made a lot of people think that I was a
larger and tougher person than I am like
like people who know me I think almost
couldn't believe what was going on after
that film because like you know I'm like
six feet tall and I weigh 160 if I'm you
know not in great shape like I have thin
wrists I'm not I'm not a big I'm not
naturally big so it was so it was a it
was a challenge for me to to put you
know that kind of weight on and um so I
just did you know many things you'd be
more familiar with than almost anybody I
you know I I calorie loaded I a lot of
lifting for a long time for the further
for the first portion of it really just
didn't you know concern with like like
leanness at all just just tried to get
muscle mass on I wish I'd had your book
back then but I didn't you know I didn't
probably would have helped me out but
but I you know I did my own version of
it increased increased diet increased
protein all that stuff and then minute I
did it sort of the old-fashioned blunt
force way mostly just a lot of probably
much more than had I read your book sort
of you know your your minimum effort
kind of Maxim I was probably going way
beyond the bell curve in terms of effort
required to get the result but that's
what I did
and then as we approached the film I
moved in to kind of like you know just
fat-burning mode and I I was I was
running I was doing everything I could
to lean out because the the camera is a
cameras a magical thing it doesn't it
doesn't actually see absolute scale it
really only sees things relative so you
don't know how tall Al Pacino really is
unless he's standing
- you know Schwarzenegger like or
whatever like wait and and you don't
actually know how big a person is and
lots of people you know I had I had gym
rats come up to me and go like would you
would you you know
g'way two bucks on that G weight buck 90
like whatever and I was like no I wasn't
that big you know what I mean but we but
if you get form and definition the
camera sees that and if you put people
around you which we did very
conscientiously who are smaller so like
the actor guy Torry who played the the
guy in jail the black guy in jail who he
becomes friends with we we cast he was
terrific but he was also really really
small and it made me look really really
big and those things those things um
inflate the perception of how big you've
gotten but um it was hard I was hard but
I really enjoyed it was the eating more
challenging of the training more
challenging the the eating was more
challenging III had trained I was you
know I rode I rowed crew in college and
that was lightweight crew or know I
wrote heavyweight crew ya Widow's
heavyweight what's the there's not
nothing it's lightweight has a cut off
but heavyweight doesn't um I was like I
was not like a varsity I rode my
freshman year and I rode my sophomore
year but frankly I probably should have
rode lightweight because I I I was you
know at my absolute maxed out I was I
probably weighed 175 when I was really
really big and strong and 19 years old
and everything and you know and the guys
who were true like varsity a class
rowers wait mom they were like 2 to 15
you know guys and there's a whole other
thing but I loved it I loved it and um
and and so training I was a runner I did
one kind of ultra marathon kind of thing
I I wasn't training hard wasn't a new
thing for me but but building bulk was
and did you was that self directed or
did you hire someone to help you with
that um I did a lot of my own but no I
did I had a guy
um his name is eluding me right now I
never I never worked with him again or
had contact with him again after buddy
Tony he was terrific yeah he designed
designed the protocol yeah designed it
for me and wouldn't uh when were you
introduced to acting or how did that
come to be and I try and I did do a fair
amount of reading and for whatever
reason wasn't able to pin it down
exactly I mean the summer camp came up
but I don't know where things yeah I
mean mostly but you know my um my mother
was an English teacher she was a high
school English teacher and was a real
theatre aficionado both my parents were
theatre aficionados and film lovers and
stuff like that and but my they exposed
me very early on to the theater and
plays and I I had a strong pull toward
that from the time I was five years old
even I started I i a babysitter of mine
went and I signed up at the theatre at
the theatre arts program outside of
school that she was involved in and
that's how that's how I got involved in
it um
and I you know I went through Epson
flows I loved it I loved it it wasn't it
wasn't like I knew I wanted to be an
actor I just liked doing it and I loved
writing stories I I wrote I made up my
own comic books and I made little VHS
camcorder films where you use the pause
button to as your cut you know what I
mean and um just all that stuff I love
not exclusively not in a way where I
knew it was my life as an adult and then
I and then I got really self-conscious
about it in high school like I didn't I
went to a public high school it didn't
seem cool to me at all
I was doing my athletics and things but
um and the Athletics were at that time
what and I didn't like laid I played
tennis I played baseball I played ice
hockey
where was that I ran track in uh in
Columbia Maryland okay yeah it's like
like half an hour south of Baltimore
mm-hmm and who were your first then uh
mentors in the world of theater the
woman who created this this local
theater arts school in our community Inn
in Columbia Maryland her name was Toby
Ornstein and it's crazy to say but she
really was um I still think she's one of
the great minds I ever encountered on
theater the craft of theater the craft
of acting she was not a regional theater
hobbyist she was like I she was my
Stella Adler really like when I was
young and infused us when we were really
young with I don't know a sense of
seriousness about it and of you know
Kratt like when you're young and you
know told us to read and told us to like
be erudite on plays and and it was it
was really interesting and then um I
like I said I got kind of in my teens I
got kind of self-conscious about it and
then I saw I saw Ian McKellen do a
one-man show in Washington DC when I was
about 17 and it was it was so it had
such a huge impact on me that I I
thought I thought wow this is something
you could actually do as a as a as an
avocation you know I mean this is
something that you can do as an adult
and it's and it's like big and important
and meaningful that's how I felt about
it then and then I still didn't really
have a notion that was going to commit
myself to that until a couple years
after college even clears after college
after major in college or when I studied
history I got a degree in history mm-hmm
did you in to focus on Asian Studies and
languages and stuff and the if we go
back to and I'm blanking I apologize
what was her name again the the first
woman the Toby Ornstein Toby yeah what
could you tell a story or give an
example of what type of things she would
emphasize when she was working with you
guys or particularly and I think she
just never easy for her she was great
director great mostly I think you know I
think a lot of people would
that's someone in their early life
there's always if you're lucky you have
someone when you're young who doesn't
talk down to you who doesn't who who
speaks to you as a serious person and
exhorts you to be to take something
seriously to take work seriously you
know and and if a person does that in
the right way you feel elevated like as
a young person you feel elevated you
feel like someone is someone saying to
you hey you want to be taken seriously
then take things seriously do the work
you know
don't coast you know and and and I'd say
that's what she give later when I was in
New York I had a teacher named Terry
Schreiber who ran a terrific theatre
studio in New York acting studio in New
York and he I would say I've often said
about him that the thing I admired most
about him was that he was a like a
pluralist and by that I mean he he was
he basically kind of he basically you
know rejected this notion that that has
infused I think a lot of the training of
actors that that a methodology is a pet
is you know that like one methodology
holds the key to anything he was like
basically like all of these things are
like what a forehand a backhand volley a
serve are to a tennis player so that is
you know the the Lee Strasberg method
the Stella Adler imagination focus the
the Sandy Meisner you know exercises he
basically just said if you don't get
yourself conversant with a lot of shots
you're just not going to be great like
you're not gonna you're not going to be
able to address material with diverse
skill sets as called for you know and I
mean and and I thought that was that
really resonated with me because I was
really turned off by Dogma right sounds
like the Bruce Lee of acting in
performance
in the sort of the ya-ya except what is
useful reject was uselessness uniquely
your own not exactly exactly I never
thought of it that way but that's yeah I
agree I am
I've always been insecure on stage and I
still pace around like a nervous wreck
for every time I get up to give a
keynote or whatnot I'm actually taking I
wasn't planning on asking you this but
just keep in mind I'm actually taking my
first acting class as an adult at the
end of this month it's a three-day I
think it's gonna be focused on improv I
don't know exactly what the curriculum
is but what advice would you give and
it's not that I plan on acting per se I
just thought it would be a helpful
exercise to get over my fear of doing
this type of thing what what advice
might you give me it's it's um I always
I always think that one of the most
interesting things about the challenge
of representing behavior which is
basically what acting is or representing
emotion representing what everyone call
it is um that like everybody does this
all the time like very few people are
very few people are perpetually speaking
in their authentic voice you know like
the Dalai Lama my but but I think he's
got his moments where he's sort of
playing the role of a monk you know what
I mean as well and we just we put on
faces we put on we put on postures we we
adapt who we are depending on the
circumstances that we're in all the time
and people do it seamlessly all the time
and and unselfconsciously
and yet the minute that you tell someone
that other people are gonna watch them
do anything definitely I think when you
put a camera on someone the affective
self-consciousness is so profound on the
on people's inability to do that which
is completely natural to them at all
times
and most times in their lives and and I
almost think like as soon as you put
someone on stage where you put a camera
on someone it's like if there's a circle
and on one side of the circle is
naturalistic you know behavior as soon
as you throw someone staged it hurls
them to the other side of the circle and
they immediately become wooden unnatural
they make they make choice they become
unable to and a lot of that has to do
just with tension and and a sense of
urgency nerves you know I think like the
old fight a fight-or-flight thing like I
think this is a weird thing to reference
but you know there's these there's these
great like you there's this European
show that was like a candid camera type
show it did a lot of things like where
they were scaring people or setting up a
situation of you know a ticking suitcase
in front of a of a train station and and
what's amazing is how paralysis is
actually the most common response like
people imagined in their minds what
their behavior is gonna be when
presented with certain stimulus or
circumstances but the truth is is that
people go into a stone-cold freeze in
many many situations you know and
there's a lot of studies on this unlike
the you know the behavior of crowds and
all that stuff like right will they
getting stabbed the street 40 people who
all expect someone else to do right
right and also just because I think it's
something deeply biological like there's
a lot of safety and freezing you know
what I mean but I think that it's very
hard for people to find a comfort a
relaxed comfort let alone a sense of
pleasure within the idea that they're
they're performing in front of other
people
right and
his and and so they start to they stop
listening
you know they stop they they start doing
what I would call up the middle choices
like they start they start painting in
the color blue instead of doing the
little things that um that that the I
can't explain it at a moment we could
actually call for the a one of the best
stories I ever heard about young people
in an acting class and you know the
difference between sort of what happens
to people typically and what are a real
authentic kind of genius is is that
Harry Belafonte talked about being in an
acting class with Marlon Brando and they
were both like literally like 19 or 20
years old in Greenwich Village and I
think he said that there was a it what
they said was okay one person is in a
one person's in his apartment and the
other one enters you're the person who's
on your couch in your apartment
the other one enters scene ensues you
know just like run just run with it and
all these people were doing all these
kind of um you know sort of forced
conversations or trying to create a
scenario or something and supposedly
Marlon was sat on the couch and started
reading a magazine and whoever it was
with his him walked in his door and he
looked up and jumped up and grabbed the
guy by the shirt front and threw him out
the door and slammed the door and
everybody was like what are you doing
he's like I don't know who that [ __ ]
guy is like he just walked into my
apartment like it scared the [ __ ] out of
me you know what I mean and it's like oh
wait ahead yeah there probably wouldn't
be a scene there probably wouldn't be a
conversation there'd be a like like who
are you super awkward confrontation
exactly like get out and I and I was the
most obvious true thing that you would
do which is wonder you know and what the
up the middle choice have been in that
scenario or what is that like what do it
is another example of that because I
well better understand I don't know
there's a great you know I I think that
uh you know when put it this way there's
an argument and there's something about
the writing of a scene that indicates
the lines would have indicates stress or
it indicates anger but the thing is that
people so then the up the middle choice
is to raise your voice and be angry but
but what we all I think no on some deep
level and we watch people performing who
who really grab us is that they they
they have an intuition for the choices
that reflect the way that those things
actually manifest themselves sometimes
like people who are angry you know
sometimes laugh they they laugh or they
or they go into silence or they gonna
slow burn like like anger doesn't mean
volume but but but if there's an
exclamation point on the end of the
sentence and the script they'll go with
that exclamation point as opposed to
there's a great there's a great there's
a there's this film I love called the
French Lieutenant's woman the French the
French Lieutenant's woman yeah it's
Meryl Streep and Jeremy Irons and I
think it's I think either Harold Pinter
or Tom Stoppard about the script i but
um the there's a scene toward the end
when Jeremy Irons excuse me it's okay
Jeremy Irons character has a girl I'll
say it again there's a scene toward the
end where Jeremy Irons character is been
looking and looking for Meryl Streep and
he he finds her after literally years of
searching and he's become angry and and
they they go to have a conversation and
he's so angry and over rod and
he goes to leave and she moves to stop
him and he takes her and sort of in
anger and seized her by the shoulder and
sort of pushes her out of the way
and and it's it's one of the cameras set
three steps down in a low recessed room
and they're up these three steps and
clearly it was a planned thing where he
was throw her and she did a you know a
staged fall down sort of right into the
camera and and very dramatic and then
he's he's struck by his violence and he
goes to pick her up and and the scene
continues on and I'm and if you watch I
remember watching it and suddenly
realising that if you watch it closely
he throws her down and she strikes her
head on the floor you can you can see
that she hits her head on the floor and
you can see if you look carefully that
her reaction she really hits her head
and you can even see it more on Jeremy
Irons that that he realizes she struck
her head and his reaction is is so
alarmed he is broken totally out of the
scene for a moment runs to her picks her
up and if you watch it really closely
you can see that he is checking in with
her the actress for a second and he's
about to open his mouth I think and and
just you know stop and say are you okay
and she puts her hand up over his mouth
like like as though to say I I'm not
work we're going on and he realizes that
she's still in it and and covers his own
mouth with his hand to stop from smiling
and and what she does in this moment
where you would think you know the whole
thing is very melodramatic and she just
lets she does this laugh and that thing
and I used to watch it because it's the
strangest it's just the strangest most
wonderful choice but it's so true cuz
she's just like it's completely absurd
she's just laughing at the absurdity of
it all and laughing at these things and
then the scene sort of settles and they
go into this gentle conversation
everything but it's it's amazing it's
why she's like one of the great great
greats of all
because she like I think it's a
completely counterintuitive choice and
it's a and it's a great example of like
two great actors and one of them is even
about to break out of because like oh
wow something's happen that wasn't
supposed to happen so we should stop and
she's like no that's real you know
something's happened it makes it really
really interesting now so let's not stop
and and it's beautiful
that level of judgment under duress it
makes if it's just thinking of a
battlefield medic or something like that
I mean having the presence of mind to
put the hand over the mouth yeah it's
good I asked them both about it and got
confirmation that that's what happened
so I know I'm not like imagining it if
you were say directing a film and you
had the opposite experience you had a
novice actor who was intimidated to say
by the people around them and they were
paralyzed for whatever reason or being
too robotic what what would you do or
say to kind of knock them out of that
hmm it's tough it really if it's a bad
it could be a bad question a lot of my
depth it depends on this situation I
mean I think it's the interest the thing
that makes that work all is interesting
so much of the time is that it's it's
just it's it's a chemistry there's a
chemistry between the people involved
that's unique every time it's it's a
it's the dynamics are are are
unpredictable and fluid and very unique
to the people involved and you have to
you really have to find your way like
every time i i think one things i like
about it is that i if I walk on if I
walk into those situations feeling
confident I think that I probably been
working too much you know what I mean
like I almost think it's it it's almost
better to feel at sea if it's good if
it's complex and it's a it's a it's a
lot of
uncertain discovery in the beginning and
that that the sense that the sense that
you're that you're at a loss or you're
finding your way and you're you know
means that you're in you're involved in
something worthwhile I think if it's if
it's if you're cruise if you're cruising
and it's a thing that it's probably not
that interesting if I mean you you've
spent obviously a lot of time honing
your own craft you've spent a lot of
time with masters of in many different
fields I'm curious if you have any
impressions or recollections of Hicks
and Gracie when you were filming The
Incredible Hulk were you able to spend
any time with him or did you yeah yeah a
little bit um not as much as I would
have liked to I it's funny I started
when I was in when I was in college I
started studying Aikido and you know
that was the era that was exactly when
uh uh hoist Gracie won the first you
have been like 92 or something yes
exactly Ronin and maybe I started saying
but I you know and and I like I said I'm
not I'm not a huge person I'm tall and
everything but one of the things that
drew me to Aikido was that it it had a
lot of it was one of the first things I
experienced where understanding physical
leverage really persuaded me that a
smaller person could could I don't want
to say defend themselves but that
doesn't technique actually worked on a
smaller person who was with a larger
person I always felt like with certain
things I had studied that ultimately
like if a person's bigger and stronger
and faster they're just gonna they're
gonna you know steamroll you and and
Aikido was one of the first things I
ever experienced where much smaller
people were commandingly over you know
overmastering much bigger people
and and when and when hoist Gracie won
that UFC I mean it was it was it's hard
to overstate the impact of that like I
mean if you're interested in these types
of things he that rewrote that rewrote
people's sense of what the priorities in
you know in martial arts should be that
you had after that like you had to be a
grappler you had to be a jiu-jitsu
artist you couldn't you know you you you
couldn't just be like a striker and and
they and they were let you know so they
were legend and I was I was interested
in Japanese studies and I hit on things
like that so I was the whole thing of
the great season their form of jiu-jitsu
was like was like I was very interested
in all that so meet so I I wrote it I
wrote into the script that he's doing
breath training with someone in Brazil
and I wrote in parentheses um you know
like like Hickson Gracie but you like
one of the Gracie's but you'll never get
who will never get them I knew I was in
parentheses on the script and then we
found out he was down there and
everything him you knows it was amazing
he's the those guys are magicians you
know they're they're they're really
really uh like Ricky J's to magic or you
know Kelly Slater is to surfing it's
like when you're when you are when
you're with someone who's got that level
of you know alpha over everybody else
that's really really really neat yeah
for those people listening you don't
know who Hickson Gracie is it doesn't of
course cover it completely but this
check out the documentary choke I don't
know if you've ever seen that it's it's
a great introduction to not only Hicks
him but also gives it a decent dose of
of Japanese culture now you spent time
in Osaka is that right how long were you
there now I was there for a long summer
between my junior and senior year and in
college I had a job over there and what
attracted you to Asian culture or
Japanese culture
I was I was interested in in yeah I mean
I wish I could say it was something more
evolved than then the Richard
Chamberlain miniseries of so Shogun but
I think it was that yeah I think I saw I
when I was a kid I think the Shogun was
on then that I went in red clay bells
book and then and then I you know
devoured a lot of his Asia sort of
historical novels and thought they were
really need and and then it you know it
uh it kind of grew from there and then I
became interested in in in Buddhism you
know history of Buddhism and stuff like
that and Japanese aesthetics really
appealed to me and the idea of Zen
really captivated me when I was like in
my late teens and stuff like that and I
I am that was all just what pulled me
into it and then then I love spending
time over there and stuff and then late
you know and then one of my advisors one
of my professors was one of the great
Chinese modern Chinese historians
Jonathan Spence
and he wrote like to me the definitive
book about modern Chinese history called
the search for modern China and just
death of a woman want to change China
all these great great great books and uh
and he was a phenomenal he really
activated history you know he really
like was one of those people who I
thought his lectures were just fantastic
and um and
that that drew me into that interest why
did you decide to major in history
because I realized my freshman year that
I had no natural Mozart like talent for
math and so that my dreams of like being
Carl Sagan or a great astrophysicist
were probably gonna be hampered by my by
my poor grasp of even you know complex
math let alone like physics and so I so
that became a hobby and a passion but
not you know and I realized I I probably
was a humanities major but I know III
really I've always really liked reading
I've always really to me like studying
history and travel or almost like the
same thing it's like I having a sense of
like you know how things became the way
they are and how people became the way
they are is really interesting to me
humans in New York so I've had quite a
few fans asked me to explore this a bit
can you explain to people your how you
came to be what is humans in New York
and had you come to be involved with it
I'm not involved with it to be clear I I
my sister turned me on yesterday my
sister turned me on to the site and and
I think a couple of my friends in New
York mentioned it to me and it just I
liked it I thought the site was really I
don't even have to call it a blog a
portrait series you know it's a
it reminded me to academic but the the
there's a great there's a great American
cultural anthropology Studs Terkel you
know and he Studs Terkel was like the
great chronicler of American working man
and the kind of the common man kind of
Pro you know he was the the Depression
era version of of that and and I feel
like I feel like what this guy's got
going with humans of New York is like a
modern-day Studs Terkel kind of thing
and I and it's it's just great if you're
a New Yorker or anybody it's a it's a
really really cool Vantage on unjust
people and and so actually again my
sister just flipped him it said have you
seen this series he's got going and he
had just launched this series of
profiles that he was calling the Syrian
Americans about about he'd gone to
Turkey to photograph an interview and
profile people who were getting asylum
in the US and we're coming you know as
though to say okay like let's meet who
these people really are and get out of
the demagoguery of it all and just sort
of see and I and you know if you if you
looked at any of them they are
incredibly incredibly affecting stories
and how did that intersect then with
Crowdrise well Crowdrise
just last year at the be about this time
last year we we made the decision to
expand from hosting only peer-to-peer
fundraising projects and crowdfunding
projects for registered nonprofits and
charities to also letting people raise
direct assistance for other people you
know
people who wanted to raise medical costs
for a friend who had an accident or some
a friend who'd lost their house and if
you know so we we we decided to support
fundraisers with where people could help
friends or loved ones with medical costs
crisis education costs tuitions things
like that and partly because so many
people who use Crowdrise
were asking us that they preferred to
keep using their Crowdrise profile pages
and and mount those types of projects
rather than have to go off site to these
frankly in my opinion fairly shitty
exchange utilities as I call them like
places that are just transactional
platforms with no real strategic support
no long-term capture of your personal
philanthropic narrative and and the
charge in my opinion way way way too
much
so because Crowdrise on the charitable
you know on the charity side had already
pioneered kind of mechanisms for
delivering donated dollars through at a
incredibly reduced rate compared to
other platforms often we're able to
offset even the credit card fees so
charities were already excited about and
benefiting from being able to get their
donation dollars through at cheaper than
they can on their own websites and as I
was looking at the sites that support
direct assistance fundraisers and I was
looking at the rates of charge I was
just like screw this man we need to we
need to make we need to make our pricing
model available to people who are trying
to help their friends and family and so
we did I hadn't used that I hadn't even
used that functionality on our own site
and when I saw that story I decided I
was gonna do my first you know direct
assistance fundraiser to help that
family and and if we raised enough to
help a couple of the families in the
series and how did the campaign do
the can't the campaign was tremendous it
it raised it raised the first 300,000 in
in like 30 hours I mean it really it
really went fast and then and then it
climbed toward I think we're at you know
four hundred and sixty thousand or
something like that across the next day
or two and what's fascinating I think
just you know to give huge credit to
Brandon and who's the founder of humans
in New York and the photographer and
writer and he we I didn't even we didn't
put it out in any kind of Crowdrise
social media or mine or anything like
that we just Brandon I set up the page
and Brandon posted on humans of New York
and a huge increment of that was driven
in very short order and I think
donations that averaged 26 bucks or 27
bucks just from the humans of New York
reader base and then we expanded it we
let some media be done on it and stuff
like that and I think when all said and
done we'll probably get up to half a
million but um I I loved it you know III
I loved seeing I loved seeing that you
know for the price of three venti
Frappuccino z-- people could without
putting any kind of a dent or making any
kind of a stretch in their own capacity
just make the the emotional gesture of
responding to a story that touched them
and and demonstrate that in aggregate if
people will do this you can you can
generate transformative impact as a
crowd and that's that's the essence of
why we set Crowdrise up and I think um
it was it was it was pretty thrilling
like we had a lot of people on the crowd
rise staff and Brandon at humans New
York we were all just like you know we
were all pretty pretty emotional about
it it was it was really it was really
cool to see it unfold and I think by the
way again that wasn't
it really was not a function of anything
particular to my public profile at all
it really wasn't it was driven I think
it was driven almost exclusively by the
authentic passion of the humans of New
York reader base who also were
responding to the story and just were
happy that someone had created the
vehicle to all gather around and respond
together and I and I think that you know
I think that that's available to all of
us that's what I like about it I don't I
don't think I think you and I were
talking about this earlier I think you
know we're in this very strange time
where like resource concentration is a
real you know it's a it's a real thing
like people can say whatever they want
but the the relative share of national
wealth is being held by in larger and
larger increments by fewer and fewer
people and at the same time we're
cutting you know aspects of the social
safety net and food stamps as our friend
Tony Robin points out and and I think
that you know one of the things that's
exciting about the the networked world
and the sort of the distributed the
empowerment of a distributed culture of
people outside of government agencies
outside of corporate constructs outside
of everything to be able to assemble and
rally together is that people can
proactively address things like that we
can move resources without anybody
else's say-so
we can decide you know we can decide
that we want to get together around
things and and assemble resources and
make things happen like in with
incredible speed like incredible speed
and I think that's really really
exciting and what you mentioned also
which i think is worth underscoring part
of the reason I've been so excited by
crowdfunding of many different types
he's like you said you you can not only
affect change in some cases massive
change with incredible speed you can do
it without any given individual
suffering a decrease in their quality of
life yeah or discretionary income or
anything else yes you have just a
thousand tiny movements that build this
groundswell they can then so
get something to escape velocity and
I've had a fantastic experience working
with the Crowdrise team and for those
people interested and it you mentioned
Tony Tony's also behind this I think
that depression and sort of the mental
health research in the u.s. has a long
way to go and particularly with a
classic compounds that could be called
entheogen z' they could be called
psychedelics but I'm working with a team
at johns hopkins roland griffiths and
we're looking at or we will be
conducting a pilot study using
psilocybin for the addressing of
treatment-resistant depression so
depression major depression that in
subjects that is not responded to SSRIs
or other types of therapy and
preliminary data would suggest that one
dose has a rapid substantial and
sustained effects um in some cases up to
six months with anti-depressive effects
and so we'll be not only conducting the
administration of the psilocybin but
also using things like functional MRI to
track and analyze it so we can hopefully
determine how to safely best administer
psilocybin or some analog of that and
what's so cool about is that it takes
the study would cost a lot less than
people might expect to eighty thousand
dollars and have a roster of thought
leaders from different areas who are in
support of this including Tony so for
people who want to check that out and
also just check out Crowdrise as a
platform and and see how well the the
entire page is put together you can go
to Crowdrise comm forward slash tim
ferriss whether you know how to spell it
or not any misspelling probably go to
the same place so grata rise dot-com for
such tim ferriss no link to that in the
show notes is there anything else you'd
like to mention about well no I think I
think I do I love that we're gonna we're
gonna work with you on this because I
also think that um
I was having this conversation with Tony
Robbins yesterday because he like you
has a terrific community of people that
rally around the ideas and and that you
that you share and pull together and
source for people and I think um I do
think it's again it to me what you're
doing and the notion that it doesn't
matter that Tony could write a check for
it or you could read check for it or
whatever then the notion that that you
can open up a serious conversation about
a blind-spot you know a call a blind
spot that we've got about you know the
potential in something being taken off
the table as an opportunity for people
because it's going to get you know
lumped in to a category of drugs viewed
as negative you know what I mean and I'm
and is just it so it's it's crazy but
the idea that you know there's actually
in many ways I think there's much more
potency in the idea of of people of
common mind about the rationality of
something rallying to the tune of twenty
five bucks apiece to collectively say
let's let's make this happen like let's
make this happen we don't need a
foundation we don't need a rich person
we don't need a you know say so from the
NIH we're gonna make this happen I think
I think it's like actually kind of like
a 21st century expression of like if you
go back if you go back and read de
Tocqueville's democracy in America you
know he's this french guy visiting
America in the 1830s or whatever and
commenting on like what is it like he
basically one of the most notable things
he says is he goes around and says like
these people just start organism a just
they just get together
and get things done is basically what
he's saying he's like all he'd comments
on all the civic groups and all the
community organizations and all the
trade get you know he basically is
amazed by what what self Pro pro active
self organization Americans do and this
is you know nearly two hundred years ago
and I think and I love it I think this
is exactly what you're doing is exactly
that it's like saying hey in this forum
that you've got we can get this done
let's let's rally together and do it and
I think that's uh I think we've only
really scratched the surface of of the
potential in rallying crowds of people
around needs ideas you know businesses
it's it's it's um we're in the we're in
the earliest earliest infancy still
maybe not the earliest we're people
people who poo pooed it at first have
now had to acknowledge that it's a force
but I think it's still got a I think
it's still gonna mature and and become
an even bigger part of our of our kind
of cultural practice almost oh I agree
and I think that either the reason just
a bit on what you said the reason that
I'm not just say funding this one study
is that I really believe having just
observed millions of people now in my
various outlets and on the blog and so
on for almost ten years hard to believe
next year is the tenth anniversary or
the first book it's insane but is that
most people do not attempt great things
because they don't believe they can
perform or achieve great things because
I think in part the the word great
implies something of massive magnitude
that in genders a lot of self-sacrifice
and I think with the technology that we
have now what I want people to
experience firsthand is that they can
participate make a very small chess move
themselves and moving that pawn forward
one square that collectively with
everyone else doing the same wins the
the equivalent of like the World Series
and puts a real positive dent in the
universe like with this study is a
chance for people to become potentially
part of history I mean it's it's a it's
it could really be in Archimedes lever
in reinventing how we look at treating
depression and doing so a fewer side
effects and to do that participate even
if it's one dollar twenty-five dollars
or just say hypothetically zero dollars
but you tell ten other people about it
right and in that way participate well
that's that's that's part of what you're
talking about in terms of leverage is
what it is also I think a part of it
almost like the philosophical conviction
we have at Crowdrise which is that
people's capacity to affect change is
not a function of their financial
capacity it's that everybody in the
world we're living in has in a dozen for
a dozen assets they can leverage that
their you know their Facebook page their
social networks their you you know their
friends and family their schools their
institutions their companies everybody's
got networks now it's not just the
rolodex anymore it's now there's a mini
network effect around everybody and
available to everybody but they have
their energy they have their creativity
their have their passion and they have
their tools now that let so many more
people from the comfort of their couch
exert their brain their creativity
without like massive logistical and cost
constraints on them and so where's we're
saying it all the time like you know
it's it's not even a question of whether
you've got even the capacity to donate
25 bucks to a psilocybe and study it's
like if you believe in it almost
everybody can ask twenty friends for ten
bucks and and donate 10x their personal
capacity you know it's like you can do
anything that you care about you
actually can affect now and I think one
of the reasons like we we set Crowdrise
up as a
as not a kind of a use and drop
evaporative platform but a place where
like a Facebook or Twitter it's a
permanent staging ground for a certain
type of activity that you're doing is
that we we think people get proud when
they do these things they're proud to
participate they're proud of the things
they've done and and so we give them the
opportunity to stage multiple projects
over time and capture the aggregate
narrative of everything they've done
year over year you know that's why we'll
do this with you and then you'll do
something else and we'll do it again and
we'll do it again and soon it won't just
be the the individuated success of these
projects that it sort of evaporate it'll
be like Tim's impact page will will show
the tote you know it'll be a way of
looking at the totality of what you've
done over time and I think I think
that's really really that's the
difference in a true platform versus
what I would call just a payment utility
no I and this to me is and this has a
lot of for those people who have heard
my my podcasts with James Fatemeh nor
add an angle and Martine plunk I mean
this these types of compounds have had a
huge impact in my life in ways that I
couldn't have imagined possible and so
it's it's less a transaction or even a
campaign in my mind then the beginning
of a movement and so I felt like it was
it was the right match you want
stickiness you know you want you want
recurrence you want like you want a I'm
a micro platform turnkey made easy for
you that that becomes something that can
sustain you know do we have some time
for a few more questions yeah when you
hear the word successful who is the
first person who comes to mind and wife
my dad is up there my dad my brother you
know I I'm not sure Pete I'm not sure
it's about people who spring to mind so
much is that like I definitely find that
almost in that childlike way of like
role modeling now in my life when I meet
people who seem like they've got they've
got their aspirations and their
engagement in balance with a lot of time
for contemplative time family time
personal health physical health
I tend to look at that and go wow like I
want to be like that guy or that woman
you know that that they I definitely
have seen more than enough people with
success as defined by notoriety or money
or whatever who look like like the
specter of you know despair to me like I
I've seen I've seen as I'm sure you have
like lots of people you know with the
Albatross of success around their neck
that seem like an intense cautionary
tale to me like I'd rather you know so
so it's more I you know like my sense of
like what constitutes a health a
successful person is probably more
define now by what looks like a healthy
person how do you prevent yourself from
becoming intoxicated by the sort of
culture or cult of personality that
seems to be so prevalent in the world
of say entertainment or that obsession
with material wealth I mean it seems to
be that type of albatross seems to be
very common what if would have would
have helped you to not succumb you know
like I think I think everybody's got to
constantly like so to do battle with
like the voices in your head that the
ego and you know I mean that's what
Birdman was all about that literally I
think that the beauty of what Alejandro
took on in that film was being honest
about the degree to which voices in your
head like just hammer at you and Hammer
it you and hammer at you about what you
don't have and what what you ought to be
aspiring to and mattering you know in
the world and and and I think that
anybody very few people are really free
of that but but I think that living in
New York helps me oddly just because
it's not it's not a film industry town
it's not I'd there's so much going on
there and there's so many things I'm
interested in and involved in it it
keeps my life diverse and and when I'm
out here where we are like I I do find
that like you know like being in the
water and being able to hike and I'm a
pilot so flat you know flying and
there's just things that take you out of
your things that take me out of my head
help a lot are pretty key but I you know
I mean I'm ridiculously fortunate and I
think I have more than enough and I
think that mmm sometimes it's it's it's
it's even getting a little bit of a
taste of how much like you know material
possessions can really be a trap it's
like there is that you know the things
that you won't end up owning you kind of
maximun I think that they the I do think
it's really really true I think I think
you start realizing how much lighter you
feel when you dispense with a lot of
that stuff then it that becomes a
positive snowball you know mm-hmm what's
up what books or book
have you given most as a gift to other
people that's a good question um there
was a period where I I I really like
Antoine de saint-exupéry spoke it's
called wind sand and stars I haven't
heard that that's a that's that's like a
a great great one were you interested in
him because he was a pilot or did ya
both I was I was reading a lot of books
about flying there in theater and I
guess what postal delivery yeah yeah I
mean he's flying the mail from like the
Sahara to Paris and and from Patagonia
to Paris which is you know from yeah
that's mean it crazy for those people
who don't recognize the name also wrote
a little bit little friends yeah but you
know he's a pup
I mean winds and stars is like it's it's
it's it's as much a book about the
philosophy of life as it and and as it
is about flying it's it's like Zen and
Zen in the in the craft of flying but
it's it's just beautiful we were talking
about this earlier I really liked that
book the Black Swan yeah I gave that to
Friends of a certain type what wood type
I really enjoyed that book yeah yeah I
think it's it's an extremely like it's
an if you if you absorb it right it's
it's it's it's got a really amazing
capacity to prick certain bubbles of
delusion or help you realize bubbles of
delusion that we all operate in and it's
some things really really cool
how would not to fool yourself yeah I am
you mentioned two essays we don't have
to go too deep into the I'll just name
them and then link to them in the show
notes but there was second win second
wind yeah which was by the former
Czechoslovakian president I'm not going
to get his first name vaclav havel Havel
hav e L and then the catastrophe of
success and the author is Tennessee
Williams Tennessee Williams any context
that you'd like to provide for folks for
those two just great the catastrophe of
success is like one of the great essays
by a creative person about exactly what
you're just talking the traps the traps
that follow on achieving anything really
that you were aspiring to achieve and
then what do you what happens after that
happens you know and second wind is sort
of the same from a different perspective
more like how do you how do you have the
courage to kind of not repeat yourself
put yourself out of your comfort zone in
a creative sense but also in a life
sense and and and I think what I like
about second wind is as a playwright he
was sort of saying like that you kind of
disgorge like a point of view and you
can keep doing that but at some point if
you don't stop and go back into like
absorption mode you're gonna you're
gonna be repeating yourself first and
you have to dare to like you have to
dare yourself to to stop listen live
absorb and then try again from scratch
you know what I mean that that's like
it's a great essay it's really really
great
do you've any have favorite
documentaries many I won't name ones
that probably I love Bennett Miller's
filmed the cruise the cruise yeah
Bennett people know he directed a Capote
and Moneyball and Foxcatcher brilliant
filmmaker but I think almost my favorite
film of his is a documentary called the
cruise
what is that about it's about a guy
who's a tour he's that he's a tour guide
the hosts on the open but in New York
City who's long who's a poet and who I
keep you can't you just have to see it
looks great and I really like that one
mmm other ones people might not have
seen I really like I really like Adam
curtis's films great British documentary
and he's got that four part film called
the century of the self and then a three
part one called the power of nightmares
I think those are those are absolutely
brilliant brilliant brilliant films like
dense but really eye-opening are there
any other underrated movies that you
think people should should say that not
necessarily documentaries any any
particular movie minefield of late I
think I'm a huge huge fan of this French
filmmaker Jacques Audiard
who I think in the last few years
he put up he put up a hat-trick of films
to beat my heart skipped and then a
profit that is one of the okay yeah that
is one of my favorite films like one
that amazing III personally put a profit
as one of the three best gangster films
ever so good I think oh my god the
Godfather Goodfellas and a profit or are
at this point my three if I had to pick
three gangster films yeah they're the
best ones
just yeah if for those people who
haven't seen a profit it's I don't speak
French but again profit and the the
poster if you're looking at it on
Netflix or Amazon or iTunes or whatever
it's red and black but it's about I want
to say Middle Eastern Algerian Algerian
yeah that's right Algerian young male
who goes to prison and about
what house oh my god I won't say
anything more and and then after that
rust and bone was his next film and it's
like it's just a brilliant film Marion
Cotillard it's like one of the great
performances in the last few years and I
love those all those films and then and
I think you know at excusing the fact
that I happen to be in one of them but
but I think Alejandro in your videos
last three films in a row
beautiful beautiful was an extremely
extremely under scene masterpiece it was
in your reduce film prior to Birdman and
it's a masterpiece
it's just called beautiful yes spelled
spelled wrong it's a masterpiece and
it's it's absolutely brilliant and again
one of the greatest performances of all
in a long time and and his the third in
his triptych I think is the revenant out
right now I think the revenant one of
the great films I've seen in the last
many years it's like it's an absolute
unqualified masterpiece it's just it's
just there's like a Native American
spirit myth or straight out of a Joseph
Campbell myth or something it's just
it's just a magnificent magnificent
piece of filmmaking we could have a
whole separate conversation about about
Birdman original which we won't do today
but also one of my favourite films in
the last few years three more questions
if you could have a billboard anywhere
that said anything what would you put on
it I might put pray for surf I I don't
know I I might put the name of certain
people from high school like and just
say like so-and-so , how you like me now
but uh no I I don't know I don't know
what I would put on it I we can come
back to that you know what I you know
what I know I'm changing my answer I
would put I would put Paul Rudd cell
phone number on it
it would complete it would complete a
long-running series of jokes that would
just be perfect
I say see if we can we can all Red's
actual number please call we'll do it
we'll do a separate crowdfunding
campaign raise money for the billboard
rental what advice would you give to
your 30 year old self and could you just
place where you were at the time oh yeah
yeah I know I was I was on the last two
days of shooting a film as directing
when I turned 30 and I I think I might
tell myself at that phase to commit
myself to a few fewer things than I did
at that time that I'm still that I'm
still feeling obligated to and that
maybe I wish I had a few less of those
things like I think my a spurt my
aspiration and my sense of my own energy
and time was like limitless at that time
and now some of that has become a cage
of obligation that I would like to yeah
but I'll get there senior year in
college what advice would you have given
yourself
I might I might have told myself to go
live abroad right then should have done
it right then like for a year or two I
had lived it were brought a little bit I
should have gone and that's like when
you think everything's about to get
started and it's not and I should have I
you know I should have gone and lived I
should have gone somewhere and lived
somewhere you know interesting or
different that it would be much harder
to do later where would you where would
you choose for yourself I don't know no
I don't know should take a trip to Japan
together get you back to Japan last last
real question is do you have any ask or
request of the audience people listening
things they should do ponder or
otherwise if you're gonna if you're
looking to uh if you're looking to raise
financial support for a friend or family
member do it on Crowdrise not on other
sites cuz much more of money will go
through to them that's my uh that's my
you know entrepreneurial hat and then
mm-hmm I think uh I'd say and I'm not
even joking I think like you know stay
tuned into communities like this I think
I think it's I think these things are
really cool I think um you know maybe an
innocent put some put more simply like
just participate you know in some what I
think is cool about what you've
assembled is I think it's um it's driven
by people's desire to like not hack life
but but but be proactive and participate
and not be apathetic and I like that I
think that's I think that's a that's a
positive community and I think um I
think we all we all get really tired you
know I think modern life is a stressful
and tiring and confusing and I think
it's um I think you know Nietzsche has
that great
thing that idea of self overcoming of
like that that the over man is not like
a perfect person it's it's actually the
person who is perpetually trying to self
overcome and I really like that idea I
think I think um I think like staying
staying engaged in the idea of evolving
yourself is really cool so I think it's
it's it's awesome that you've got this
many people kind of linked up together
around those ideas yeah I I really hope
people listening no matter how small you
might feel or isolated you might feel I
know not everyone out there has a
community like you or I might have in
New York or SF you to make this year the
year that you astonish yourself with
what you can do or be a part of and you
know look back on December 31st of this
year and just sit hope to say holy [ __ ]
I can't believe I was part of X or I did
X to yourself because I don't I think
it's a lot easier than people might
think Edward where can people find you
on the interwebs on social to say hello
keep up to date with what you're not I'm
not great at it
I you know I I throat tweets out now and
then mostly about things I've seen that
I like like you're talking about things
I've seen or read that I think should
find a wider audience or that people
will appreciate I what is your some time
later just my name okay but I'm I'm not
cutting edge on I'm not a I'm not his
cutting edge I am on the crowdfunding
stuff but I'm not as I'm not his cutting
edge with social media as I as I maybe
should be I am or or I don't know maybe
it's a good thing probably means you've
melted less of your brain yeah I think
about it you know I think about like
like
expanding on you know more robust ways
of kind of doing like like what you're
doing in a much smaller way bit building
up more of a forum of interactive
conversation but I'm I'm doing I'm I got
it I got a I got it I got a I got a
finish
you're gonna finish things I started
might be a cage within a cage this is
always fun I enjoy hanging out and I
appreciate you taking the time
definitely sounds super fun I really am
I've I've I've really enjoyed your books
I've enjoyed the kind of I've enjoyed
him as a resource and and I think
learned a lot and and and I think it's I
really do think it's cool that that what
you've cultivated is people who are
people who are interested in in in in
continuing to explore you know like like
I think it's it's that idea ongoing
education ongoing discoveries the you
know that's the zest and things yeah you
don't you don't necessarily find
yourself you create yourself one little
step at a time so Edward thank you again
and to everyone listening check out
Crowdrise comm forward slash tim ferriss
to see what mischief productive mischief
i'm getting up to and as always you can
find the show notes links to everything
we talked about 4-hour workweek comm
forward slash podcast end until next
time thank you for listening thanks that
we go
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me or
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront and this is a very unique
sponsor wealthfront is a massively
disruptive in a good way set it and
forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it and
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally art great investing
is a marathon not a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic tax
loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than ten asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first fifteen thousand which is
managed for free if you use my link
wealthfront com forward slash Tim that
is less than five dollars a month to
invest a thirty thousand dollar account
for instance now normally when I have a
sponsor on this show is because I use
them and recommend them in this case
it's a little different I don't use
wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of now I do have to read a
mandatory disclaimer wealthfront Inc is
an SEC registered investment advisor
investing in securities involves risks
and there's the possibility of losing
money past performance is no guarantee
of future results please visit wealth
front comm to read their full disclosure
so check it out guys this is one of the
hottest most innovative companies coming
out of Silicon Valley and they're
killing it they've become massively
popular just take a look see what
portfolio they would create for you and
you can use that information however you
want wealthfront comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business is a logo
website business card thumbnail or any
other design I recommend checking out 99
designs I use them myself I've used them
for many years I use them to create book
cover prototypes for the 4-hour body
which went on to becoming number one
York Times best seller I've also used
them for banner ads illustrations and
much more with 99 designs you get a
variety of original designs from
designers around the world give your
feedback and then pick your favorite
your happiness is guaranteed so check
out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and
designs from fellow Tim Ferriss shell
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
dot-com forward slash Tim and until next
time thank you for listening